well it's nice to have the final say on
things but it's very lonely if I think
when you call yourself an outer or a you
know when people use that right you know
that phrase at the beginning of a film
us a film by such as such because as
well as written and directed by it's
like you people have this obsession with
kind of how many times going to get my
name you know in the credits that feels
very pretentious to me so I've always
eschewed that idea but but I you know to
me the collaboration is very important
you know I it is it's important to be
able to celebrate with somebody at the
end of the day but knowing that you have
the final say in creative matters is
important as well I mean I've worked as
a person for hire as well as the person
who's in you know in charge and I prefer
the in charge in a way you you are more
open to input if you have the comfort of
knowing that you have the final say it's
the people who always think they're
going to get is are the ones that
do get the ones they're afraid of
you know the studio or someone just
clamping down on the star you know
crushing some beautiful idea tend to
have this attitude of you're going to
hurt me and looking for trouble rather
so that notes aren't received in a very
open way there you know there's a
knee-jerk reaction against them people
don't always know that but when you have
a director who is does have the final
say within budget they tend to be more
relaxed and really open to what could
very well be good notes you know and I
like all kinds of input I have a lot of
screenings I have friends I have
strangers you know giving me their
opinion as long as I know I'm not going
to be forced into something that's
important to me obviously when you get
into larger budgets you have less of
that freedom
ah and I just I'm not a person that
tends to make stories for those larger
budgets to me it's not much fun to have
that kind of pressure so I don't know
fault I've been pretty good at seeing
notice stuff where I know it's going to
be trouble no matter how much money or
glamorous involved